we should all be feminists we teach
girls to shrink themselves to make
themselves small er we say to girls you
can have ambition but not too much you
should aim to be successful but not too
successful otherwise you will threaten
the man because I am female I am
expected to aspire to marriage I am
expected to make my life choices always
keeping in mind that marriage is the
most important now marriage can be a
source of joy and love a mutual support
but why do we teach girls to aspire to
marriage and we don't teach boys the
same we raise girls to see each other as
competitors not for jobs or
accomplishments which I think may a good
thing but for the attention of men we
teach girls that they can't be sexual
beings in the way their boys are
feminist feminist feminist feminist
feminist feminist feminine the person
who believes in the social political and
economic equality of the sexes a
feminist is a man or a woman he says yes
that is a problem with gender as it is
today and we must fix it thank you for
watching for more videos like these
please subscribe to glamour UK by
clicking this button flicks the button
here
you